all right so uh
our first talk of the session is brian
o'gorman uh
from uc berkeley and telling us about
electronic structure and fixed basis
uh so yeah so i'll be talking about uh
the computational complexity of the
electronic structure problem
uh this is joint work with sandy irani
james whitfield and bill phefferman
all of them are here i should note that
this collaboration started
last spring at the simon's workshop so
it's especially nice to
be here in person presenting the results
uh so the main result of this talk is
the following that
uh determining the ground state energy
of an electronic structure hamiltonian
in a fixed basis set with fixed particle
number and to inverse polynomial
precision
is qma complete uh and you know i'll
describe later what exactly the
electronic structure problem is
but this is a reasonable formalization
of arguably the fundamental
computational problem
in quantum chemistry and then
additionally
we show that finding the lowest energy
slater determinant
of the same type of hamiltonian and the
same regime is mp complete
where slater determinants are a subclass
of quantum states
that are uh efficiently describable and
usable classically
uh so backing up a bit uh you know let's
recall local hamiltonians acting on
qudits
the the things that we're normally used
to thinking about in quantum hamiltonian
complexity
uh you know they have some uh locality
that is you know each term acts on at
most
uh some constant number of qubits uh
q-bits and non-trivially
there's some local dimension and this is
a canonical qma complete problem
maybe the canonical problem and you know
one of the reasons that we care about it
is because we think that physical
systems are
governed by such local hamiltonians
but really local hamilton physical local
hamiltonians
often have a lot more restrictions just
than locality
in this generic sense uh so we can ask
you know are
these more restricted classes of
hamiltonians still hard to find the
ground state of
so one of the first results along these
lines was showing that
you can introduce a spatial locality
even in two
in 2d uh and with qubits on a grid
uh this was shown by alibera and tear
hall goddessman and ronnie
showed that translational invariant in
hamiltonians in 1d
where translationally invariant means
that the term is exactly the same
throughout space and just repeated and
this is you know a common feature of a
lot of materials and condensed matter
physics
and then more recently piticum montenero
showed that
it's still qma hard even if all of the
terms are identical
up to a positive rescaling and this is
again a very common feature of
physical hamiltonians because it's not
just the uh geometry that that's
constrained by the physics
but also the type of the interaction and
the only thing that changes
uh from instance instance is the
magnitude of the interactions
uh that's captured by this this positive
rescale
um but you know unless you think such
progress is inevitable there definitely
have cases
uh for example traveling salesmen where
we know that
uh the problem is hard in general uh but
for realistic instances namely like you
kill
euclidean distances uh we can
effectively get as good an approximation
as we want
uh and so you know there's always it's
always an open question whether more
restricted classes of hamiltonians are
still hard
uh so that was local hamiltonians acting
on cuditz uh but a lot of the physical
systems that uh
we're interested in studying uh consists
not of uh qubits
but of indistinguishable particles and
this is manifested in a permutational
invariance
of the hamiltonian so there's a single
one local term and a single two local
term
uh and it's it's identically repeated
for every uh
cute it's in every pair of qudits
respectively and then in addition to the
permutational invariance of the
hamiltonian
we're also interested in uh only
permutationally invariant states
uh so suspicious specifically we're
interested in symmetric or
anti-symmetric uh
states and finding the lowest energy
states there
and you know for the purposes of this
talk you can just take as the definition
of bosons and fermions
uh particles whose states need to be
symmetric or anti-symmetric respectively
um and so this is you know a very
restricted type of hamiltonian
uh and yet in both cases you know there
are some results showing that it's still
hard so so
uh child's gossip and web showed that
not only generic bosonic hamiltonians
but
uh specifically the bose hubbard model
which is you know a very simple
uh but commonly used toy model of
physics
that that is qma hard and then lou
showed that at least generic fermionic
hamiltonians are
qma hard but electronic structure uh is
a very particular type of fermionic
local hamiltonian
and there's a lot of structure in the
terms that
you know potentially could be exploited
by either a quantum or a classical
algorithm
so the question is is silicon at heart
shurkin verstrada gave one positive
answer to this question by introducing
the site-specific magnetic fields and
this is you know not an unreasonable
thing to do to model
certain condensed matter systems but
typically
in quantum chemistry we there is not
an external magnetic field let alone one
that is uh finely tuned uh at different
points in space
uh and so we give a positive answer to
this question uh in a different way
by restricting the basis and i'll say
exactly what that means
so the you know model of the world
that's relevant for us here
is that we're trying to model some
molecular system uh you know molecule
consists of some nuclei and some
electrons
and it's just the fact that nuclei are
much heavier than electrons and so it's
a very good approximation
commonly taken known as the borne
oppenheimer approximation
to treat these nuclei as classical
stationary point particles
and then the problem is to solve for the
quantum electronic ground state
given the positions of these nuclei and
then there's some outer loop of
optimizing the positions of the nuclei
that's beyond the scope of this talk
so the real goal here is you know given
a model like this
uh find the ground state electronic
energy
uh but the problem is that that's an
object that exists in the continuum
continuum it's infinite dimensional and
so you know in practice
if we want to represent the state on a
computer quantum or classical
we need to discretize the problem in
some way which makes the
the practical goal um finding the
grounds the lowest energy state within a
given basis
so this is you know formally the
electronic structure hamiltonian
given some single particle bases
some set of wave functions that we'll
use linear combinations of to represent
our states
the hamiltonian is completely determined
by these
orbitals so there are three terms in the
hamiltonian
the first is the kinetic energy that all
the particles have
the second is some external potential
you know typically it comes from the
nuclei but there are more generic models
where you can model different
environments
and then lastly we have this electron
electron
coulomb interaction that is repulsive
because both of the electrons are
equally
uh charged uh and it has this one over r
scaling which is
kind of long range so so it's um
local spatially but not not exactly um
and so you know despite the the elec
despite the electronic structure
hamiltonian having all this structure
we can still prove it's hard uh in the
following way uh so
the starting point will be the hardness
of the anti-ferromagnetic heisenberg
model
uh shown by pitaka montenero and we'll
use that to get hardness of the hubbard
model
the fermi hubbard model using two main
ingredients
jordan wigner to map between fermions
and qubits
and perturbation theory to simulate the
heisenberg
hamiltonian the low energy subspace of
the hubbard model
and then once we have a hardness of the
hubbard model
we can try to construct a set of
orbitals
such that the electronic structure
hamiltonian
basically looks like this hubbard
hamiltonian at least approximately
so this is the anti-ferromagnetic
heisenberg model
anti-ferromagnetic anti-ferromagnetic
simply means that all of these
coefficients are non-negative
and we call that anti-ferromagnetic
because uh
if we're interested in ground states
this has the tendency to induce
particles into anti-alignment uh and one
you know
important feature of this hamiltonian is
that it's rotationally invariant you
know there's this uniform
uh linear combination of uh two-qubit
polys
and there's no preferred direction uh
and this will be
you know useful uh for our purposes
because ultimately we'll be reducing
from
electronic structure where we encode a
qubit
in the spin of the electron but without
magnetic fields
there's no preferred direction of the
spin and through the chain of reductions
that'll indirectly correspond to
the absence of a preferred direction in
this heisenberg hamiltonian
so we want to use hardness of the
heisenberg model
to get hardness of the hubbard model
which looks like this
it has a very simple form but
nevertheless uh
this is a hamiltonian that the
physicists believe captures at least
qualitatively
many of the important features and
dynamics of real
periodic systems there are two
parameters one is the
on-site repulsion interaction u that
prevents or penalizes two electrons from
being in the same place
so you know in general the anti-symmetry
of the states means that uh
two electrons can't be in the same state
but because there's additional spin
components of the state
they can be if they have opposite sign
and this is this is what that captures
and then there's this additional hopping
term that allows electrons to move from
one place to another
and viewing this as a computational
problem there's a computational problem
for every fixed u
and instances encoder instances are
encoded
by these weighted graphs where the edge
weights give the strength of this this
hopping term
and like i said the the hubbard model is
a hamiltonian that acts on fermions
the heisenberg hamiltonian acts on
qubits
so we need some way of mapping between
them there are many ways of doing this
we'll use the jordan wigner
transformation
so we'll take some elementary fermionic
operator on the left
and map it to a poly operator so for
example here you know this ai
removes an electron from a particular
state
which is essentially what this x minus
iy does right it's a poly lowering
operator
but then additionally there's this long
string of z's that are needed to
keep track of the anti-symmetry of the
states which is encoded in the operators
and this long string of z's is dependent
on the ordering that we choose
uh and you know in general when we map a
local fermionic hamiltonian to a cubit
hamiltonian in this way
it'll become non-local but in our case
we'll be able to choose a very
particular ordering
such that this basically becomes a
non-issue and at the end of the day
we'll get a local hamiltonian
specifically the heisenberg model
so the next ingredient is is
perturbation theory uh so we'll choose
two parameters of our hubbard model
a very large on-site uh penalty uh
and we'll set the number of electrons
equal to the number of spatial orbitals
so the on-site repulsion prevents more
than one electron from being
in any one place and then the the fact
that the number of places are equal to
the number of electrons means that
the ground state will effectively be in
a subspace where there's exactly one
electron per uh spatial orbital
but exactly in that subspace is not the
hamiltonian is not that interesting
so we'll do some perturbation theory and
to second order
we get we get the heisenberg hamiltonian
that we want at least within the low
energy spectrum
up to some error and note that
you know because we're restricting to
this half-filling subspace
the long string of z's just becomes
these constants in
the second-to-last line you know these
these signs that depend on the
indexing but then because we're going to
second order
they all cancel out and so the general
problem of non-locality from jordan
vigner
is a non-issue here but by carefully
choosing the
orbital indexing
so to recap you know we started with the
heisenberg instance and we constructed a
hybrid instance
that encodes the heisenberg instance in
its low energy subspace
by choosing very large on-sites
repulsion term and setting
the number of electrons to the number of
spatial orbitals
and then through a combination of uh
jordan wigner and perturbation theory
we can simulate the heisenberg
hamiltonian thereby showing hardness of
the heisenberg
sorry showing hardness of the hubbard
model which we can now use
to show hardness of the electronic
structure
problem so the input is you know a
hubbard model that we want to simulate
using
electronic structure so we have this
on-site repulsion and this uh
weighted graph giving the the hopping
terms
and what we want to do is construct a
set of orbitals such that the electronic
structure
hamiltonian basically looks like a
hubbard model and we'll do this
do that through a construction which uh
constructs a bunch of
primitive orbitals that will just be you
know standard gaussians in space
uh and then we'll take linear
combinations of these primitive
gaussians
and form what i'll call composite
orbitals and it's these composite
orbitals
that will be the orbitals of the
electronic structure hamilton
so you know for example if we had a
hubbard model
represented by this graph on the left
you know this graph is planar uh you
know for visual clarity
in general the hubbard model instances
that we get from the hardness proofs are
in general
non-planar and as far as we know can't
be made to be planar
but anyway so we have this input graph
and what we'll do is we'll introduce a
primitive orbital for every vertex
and a pair of primitive orbitals for
every edge um in this way where i've
lighted the the vertex orbitals um for
for visual clarity
and then what we'll do is you know we'll
take the primitive orbitals
near each vertex and combine them into a
composite orbital for for inputting into
the electronic structure hamiltonian
so for example you know these three
highlighted primitive orbitals will go
towards
the composite orbital corresponding to
the vertex between them
these three will go for that vertex and
note that if we consider
two vertices there's exactly one pair of
primitive orbitals that are very close
to each other
that we'll use to engineer the
interaction between these vertices
you consider any other fermionic for me
on qubit mappings other than the jordan
whitner
uh no because like in general different
fermionic
qubit mappings have advantages and
disadvantages
um but jordan vigner worked for our
purposes so
so there wasn't any need to consider
other ones
um i mean i think uh in the early days
that was that was a big open question i
think we did consider um
one but eventually um realized that
jordan ringer which in many senses the
simplest one
was good enough that that the general
problem the general disadvantage of
jordan wigner which is this non-locality
uh basically magically goes away uh i
mean made out magically but
uh fortuitously it was not uh designed
that way
so if we can check the orbitals in this
way uh i should know that i can't see
the questions at all so
[Music]
yeah so if we design the orbitals in
this way we have some set of parameters
that describe them specifically the
first two
are the exponents of these gaussians
we'll use
one or one exponent for the primitive
vertex gaussians and another exponent
for the primitive edge gaussians
and we'll set the um this vertex
gaussian exponent beta to be very large
which will engineer
a very large on-site propulsion
interaction and then we also have uh you
know the distances between all of these
pairs of points
in addition to some lower bound big
gamma on
what we mean by far away so we'll have
these pairs of points that are very
close together and everything else will
be
very far away so to make it negligible
and now we have these orbitals and we
want to carve out a hubbard
model so the first problem is that uh we
have these linear combination of
gaussian so they're not perfectly
orthogonal
and for most of them the the overlap is
negligible
uh they're far apart away but we have
these pairs of points that are very
close together that
we want to engineer interactions between
and the overlap is not negligible
but there is a quantitative way of
accounting for that
so that's the first step then we
remove the interactions due to things
that are far apart um and this is the
one you know approximation we make
that's sort of independent we can set
gamma
big gamma as large as we need to
and if we do that we get to a
hamiltonian that at least starts to
uh represent the the graphical structure
of the hubbard model that we want to
simulate
um but still there are some undesirable
terms in this hamiltonian
that we will neglect by setting the
parameters in a very specific way
uh and if we do all of this then we get
to essentially
a hubbard model approximately and uh you
know most much of the work
the technical work of the proof is
showing that the error of this
approximation
is small enough
so that was a qma hardness of finding
the
lowest energy quantum ground state now
let's talk about finding the lowest
energy slater determinant
so for qdit local hamiltonians
we can consider the lowest energy
product state
sometimes this will be a good
approximation to the true ground state
sometimes you know in general it won't
be or at least we don't expect it to be
but in any case it's a well-defined
computational problem
and in particular has a classical
witness we can classically describe
the product state and so for fermionic
systems the
analog is later determinants which are
really just anti-symmetrized product
states
and a common commutational problem in in
quantum chemistry
is finding the lowest energy slated
determinant which is known as the
the hartree foc problem or the hardrefox
state the the outcome of this
uh and and again in many cases this is a
good approximation to
the ground state uh but even when it's
not this uh
hartree fox state is usually a good
starting point for for more advanced uh
computational methods
and so proving empty hardness of finding
the lowest energy slater determinant
proceeds largely along the same lines we
use the exact same orbital construction
but we use we choose a slightly
different or maybe qualitatively
different
parameter regime specifically we said
all the exponents of the gaussian is
very large
so that we effectively get these
classical point particles
resulting in a diagonal classical
hamiltonian
and we have this you know again an
on-site repulsion term that will set
very large
which means that the ground state will
be in a subspace where there's no more
than one electron in each
spatial orbital and
once we've done that we we get this very
simple hamiltonian
which we can essentially use to compute
independent set
uh so if we make this analogy uh between
spatial orbitals and vertices uh whether
or not an electron
is in a particular spatial orbital uh
with whether or not it's in a particular
set
and the energy with a number of bad
edges bad edges
if someone gives us a graph and asks us
is there an independent set of size k uh
we can construct these orbitals
such that um the electronic the ground
state energy of the electronic structure
uh hamiltonian with k electrons
will be zero if and only if uh there's
an independent set of that
size so
going forward you know one of the
motivations for this work
uh is the widely held belief that
quantum computers will be useful for
solving
electronic structure hamiltonians but we
know that
you know even quantum computers have
their limits there needs to be some
upper bound on what they can do we know
they can't just solve any local
hamiltonian problem
and so the you know the question one of
the questions that we're trying to
answer
is um you know where
where is this upper bound on what what
quantum computers can do specifically in
the context of
uh quantum chemistry uh and so our work
you know uh
qualitatively improves this upper bound
you know we know that
not just our generic fermionic local
hamiltonians qma heart
but specifically ones with uh the
structure uh where the coefficients are
those of electronic structure
but still there are you know many
unrealistic aspects of the orbitals that
we construct
so in particular you know chemists are
you know in practice solve the problem
in a fixed basis but they try to do so
in a good basis
a basis that they hope captures the
actual ground state
and so i think you know further
improvements in this work we'll use
show hardness for electronic structure
hamiltonians with better and better
orbitals and also you know one thing i
sort of
um hit on the hit under the rug
is that we set the external potential to
be zero here
um whereas in reality you know there's
these uh nuclear potentials
which are exactly what keeps the
electrons you know around them in space
and so we have these uh you know two
directions of attacking this problem you
know upper bounds coming from complexity
theory
and you know lower bounds coming from uh
you know algorithm development
and we know there needs to be you know
some transition from from hardness to
easiness
either using classical or quantum
computers uh and you know
it's a very big open question you know
where this transition is
you know what is the special property
that we expect certain realistic
chemistry instances to have that would
allow them to be solvable efficiently by
a quantum computer
we know it's not just that they're
electronic structure hamiltonians
but is there some other property that we
can identify that
uh would escape these these worst-case
hardness results
and uh that's a big open question that i
think that there's a lot more work to do
to
to narrow down um and then more
generally you know i focus specifically
on the ground slate energy problem but
there are a lot of other computational
problems in quantum chemistry
so a common prive primitive in quantum
chemistry calculations is
calculating the overlaps between two
different quantum states
we're also interested in the the
spectral gap which is important for
dynamics
other properties of the ground state
besides just the energy like correlation
functions and things like that
and i think that all of these are pretty
well studied in
the context of local cudit hamiltonians
but again you know the the hamiltonians
and the instances of these problems
that arise in quantum chemistry have a
lot of structure
um and you know it's a big open question
whether
they're still hard even with all of this
structure or there's something about
that structure that can be exploited to
get efficient classical or quantum
algorithms
um that's it
um you said this you described this
construction that was an approximate
covered model and then you said you know
to make it exact you have to
follow through some uh
you have to be careful about the
approximation case is there any sort of
without getting
the details any summary as to what the
techniques are for
or what what what that looks like
yeah so
i mean so it's uh you know basically for
every
approximation that we that we make um so
okay so the first step
well you know when we orthonormalize it
changes what the hamiltonian is
but then we get a specific expression
for for what that is
um for all the other things we're
basically just throwing away terms
uh and so basically the techniques are
like
you know calculating exactly an upper
bound on the magnitude of the things
that we're throwing away
and at the end of the day we get a bunch
of constraints you know we want all of
these things to be
in aggregate smaller than
the precision to which we're trying to
estimate the ground state energy
and then it's just a matter of setting
the parameters so that all of these
constraints are satisfied
and is it delicate enough about how
these constraints are
independent or something like that yeah
so that was um
they are so the there's one constraint
that is independent
um you know this lower bound on what we
mean by far away
um we can basically set it as large as
we need to um but all of the others
are competing and so it is
um you know relatively it's non-trivial
to find the parameters that
was um you know one point we had these
constraints and
uh it was difficult to show that they
were satisfiable
and at one point we needed to tighten up
the constraints or
actually loosen up the constraints
tighten up the analysis so the
constraints weren't as
strong as they originally were so that
they could be
mutually satisfiable
all right we have a question in the q a
from one lou
the cusp condition of electronic
structure wave function will not be
exactly guaranteed
by using a linear combination of a
finite number of gaussians
is the deviation from the exact exact
cusp
condition properly bounded in the proof
can you say more about that
um so that is uh
you know when i said that these orbitals
are bad orbitals
uh that that's exactly what it meant um
and you know in particular the cusp
you know the cusp arises from uh having
a nuclear potential
uh like an external potential that is
these point positively charged point
particles
uh but here the external potential is
zero um
there's no cost because there's no
potential um
and you know that's what's unphysical
about this choice of orbitals like
we're solving the problem in this uh
in a particular particular single
particle orbital basis
uh but there's no physical reason to do
that um it's very much just matching
the syntax of the computational problem
without matching really the physics of
it
and that's i think you know the next
step in this line of work is trying to
improve that
uh and that would um
yeah that would include having uh a
point a nuclear potential
that would induce these cups and we
would need to use much more complicated
orbitals and i mean i think it's not
quite right that there's not
a um a finite number wouldn't suffice
but it's certainly not a constant number
i mean it would need to be a very large
number of
orbitals to capture at least
approximately the cost
i have a question actually on your last
slide at one end of the spectrum
was electronic structure instances of
bqp
what do we know about that space can you
say um
i think you know not
much i mean there's not much we can say
along those lines as far as i'm aware of
in terms of the directly in terms of
properties of the hamiltonian
so there are uh you know there's a lot
of great algorithmic work
for doing time evolution and so one
thing we could say
is that you know we can solve
hamiltonians for which we can do time
evolution
and for which the adiabatic algorithm
works you know in a polynomial amount of
time
but i don't know of any work that that
translates that back into like a
property of the hamiltonian
it's sort of like an operational uh
characterization
of what we can do all right and then
follow up from
there's a fermionic quantum simulator uh
you mean a classical one
oh um yeah so
if you mean that there's uh a
way to simulate fermionic dynamics
either classically or quantumly
probably quantumly um then
yeah basically exactly what i said um
that you know if we can
do time dynamics we can um do adiabatic
evolution
for at least polynomial amounts of time
and then
the implication is i mean just like in
general adiabatic quantum computing the
implication is that
there are some electronic structure
hamiltonians
for which the gap gets exponentially
small
it doesn't say anything about you know
how to find those instances
how to characterize them other than they
must exist
um if uh you know our
beliefs about the the computational
landscape are true
right
12 30.